- So you have a tradition
at the show, right?
- We do.
- I love this tradition.
- Yeah, so we share a
dressing room at our theater,
and every week we award someone
something called the Shuckey,
which is this like little statue
John crafted with his children, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And we give it every week.
It's like employee of the week,
and so we give it every week
to someone that has gone
like above and beyond
in the building.
And we would like to do our weekly award
here on air if we could.
- Do we have the Shuckey?
(audience applauding)
- Oh, yeah. So here it is.
- Oh my god, it's corn.
- John made this at home.
- I love it,
"Oh my God, it's corn."
- With the hand-painted
and mounted from some old
thing I had in my house.
- And he's prepared a speech.
- Kelly, we are so thankful
that you chose to break
away from Los Angeles.
The West coast has been
a little less bright
since you've been gone.
- Oh, thank you.
- But New York is stronger with you in it.
- I see what you're doing.
- The chemistry is real.
All I ever wanted was for Shuck
to be the first Broadway
show to perform on your show
in a moment like this.
I don't know the meaning of life.
- Oh my God.
- But gratitude has got to be part of it.
So we made the Shuckey piece by piece,
and now we present it to you.
- Thank you.
- So now Shuckey in hand,
when Christmas comes around
and you're underneath the tree,
you can tell yourself,
this is my December.
- This is my. It's mine!
- Kelly.
(audience applauding)
- That was good. (indistinct)
Thank you so much.
- My life would shuck without you.
(audience cheering)
- Sure.
- He said, "My life
would shuck without you."
- And I would like to thank Texas and....
- And who else?
- Who else?
- For all of us. For
just raising all of us.
- What's funny, is I really assumed
I was the one gettin' the trophy.
(everyone laughing)
I even moved up.
- You're like ready for your moment.
- I got the emotional face.
- Yes, yes. Not your time.
- I've done so (indistinct)
- It's my time.
- It's your time.
- Yeah.
- It's my time. Like Goonies.